dude i had people who knew me in real
life
that were [ __ ] with me really yeah
like they were either someone i knew in
high school they knew like to the t
they knew a lot of stuff about me who i
hung out with all this stuff but they
wouldn't reveal like
who they were and you know how they say
some of your biggest like haters and
harassers are the people that you
actually know
dude it was crazy like early youtube
years right they would dm all this stuff
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
we have the og returning guest
celebration
there's a pop-up shade
jojitsukawa baby
what's up man it's been a
it's been like almost i think half a
year since i've been
you've been traveling dude i know but
last time i was [ __ ] on it we you
forgot to record the video so it's just
sound hey let me tell you something
i've done that multiple times but yeah
you know what i like though uh the most
about this this whole thing are the
rumors about how we're actually not
friends and like falling out and then
there's i love like when people create
like a story yeah and then when they
create like a story about like oh
you know the reason why joe's not on
anymore is because this and they had a
fallen now and it is in a debt and then
like i get i get really interested in
all that [ __ ] do you know you know what
the crazy thing is is like you know
people are messing me like do you hear
what they say about you on reddit i'm
like yeah it's been there for a while
you know
it's it's not like you guys found out
and then i just found out recently i
there has been so much [ __ ] about us
since day one yeah for i mean we've been
on this for like what over 13 14 years
it's been a long time yeah and it's just
you know when people ask they go well
how do you deal with it it's like
there's nothing to deal with
i mean there is nothing to deal with
like you just let people have
conversation anyone if they're having
fun doing that stuff let them have fun
and if they're miserable then let them
be miserable like it doesn't matter and
it's like a lot so it's just youtube
comments it's it's not just reddit it's
a lot of other places like instagram
in the dms people talking [ __ ] i got an
email one day and this guy was like i
can't wait to kill you like yeah i mean
and this is not new nothing still hasn't
happened i think after a while you just
get i don't know it's just like fun i
remember back in the day when you know
when we first started doing youtube
youtube was such a new space i remember
when somebody would talk [ __ ] it didn't
the online stuff didn't seem like a
separate world it felt like online world
and real world were the same thing so we
would i would message people like all
right meet me up here and then we can
scrap i know not knowing that this
person's like in [ __ ]
singapore don't know who the [ __ ] this
guy is but back in the day i remember i
went right back like well let's [ __ ]
go you can meet me up at this spot and
we'll scrap like as if i was 14 years
old and [ __ ] dude i had people who knew
me in real life
that were [ __ ] with me really yeah
like they were either someone i knew in
high school they knew like to the t
they knew a lot of stuff about me who i
hung out with all this stuff but they
wouldn't reveal
like
who they were and you know how they say
some of your biggest like haters and
harassers are the people that you
actually know
dude it was crazy like early youtube
years right they would dm all this stuff
[ __ ] try to talk some [ __ ] and i'm
like all right let's [ __ ] go and then
like
gone
completely gone and then they'll come
back again and i'm like who the [ __ ] is
this that's so [ __ ] random yeah why
would they do that i have no idea till
this day i have no idea but i know it's
someone i know
so it's like someone
either a friend that was like [ __ ]
with me and he's laughing behind my back
and he just forgot about it or it's
someone who really didn't like me in
high school who never had the balls to
fight me or whatever and then they
wanted to find out how to like hurt me
there's some weird [ __ ] too because i
so
during
christmas time or whatever like you know
i tend to meet up a lot of friends with
sacramento or whatever but you can
always
tell when somebody speaks to you when
they have like an either like an
ulterior motive or like you could tell
how much they dislike you even though
they're trying to play nice yeah right
so we were having a conversation and
then out of nowhere everybody's having a
good time
and then this guy in the group randomly
just goes he goes oh so so you got like
famous and making money off of you know
all of our jokes and i was like
what what do you mean out of nowhere and
then you just getting a little awkward
and i don't usually let things pass like
that especially if you're being super
disrespectful you know in a public like
with all of our friends and i was like
bro when were you ever funny
i'm like
when the [ __ ] would i i was like bro i
mean listen i don't suggest you say this
[ __ ] but i literally looked at him i was
like you think i want to be you he goes
yeah i was like if i was you i'd kill
myself
i would literally kill myself dude what
the [ __ ] are you talking about but
literally and then after that i just
started roasting this dude for like 30
minutes as you should yeah and he just
left yeah and then after that he doesn't
come by anymore it's like dog why'd you
attack me like i didn't say anything or
do anything and the funny thing is it's
like if anything else
you are the last person that i would
have ever learned any type of humor from
you know i understand if it was like
certain people in the group they're very
funny they influenced me a lot he was
not one of them but it's just like the
idea that he had to go out of his way to
try to make me feel bad for so for what
for [ __ ] what and it's a reflection
of where that person is in his life
right now because
a lot of people in that group depending
on what we were doing everybody's
successful now yeah they're working jobs
they have that's what sucks man because
you want the group to come up together
and then there's there's frenemies
there's like people that are like like i
think what sucks the most is when you've
been supporting someone for like all
your life right and then you find out
that they were in competition with you
yeah and they're like man all i wanted
to do was like be above you and this and
that and i'm like
what'd you leave bro
what dude there was a i meant totals on
podcast a while ago but there was a guy
that um we did comedy at the same time
um
he was not very funny right
all of our friends knew that he was not
very funny we went to go see him at a
stand-up shows and we just watched him
bomb all the time he always did tiny
dick asian jokes all the [ __ ] time
and my favorite
you know what i'm saying and it's just
like just watching him go up it was
terrible and so but when i moved to la
um i just i made the big jump right i
had to make the sacrifices i had to sell
all my [ __ ] tell my parents all this
other stuff yeah and i decided to leave
well there was there was another guy too
and i'll talk about him later but this
specific guy years later out of nowhere
gives me a facebook message and he goes
hey man i saw that you're doing well
blah blah blah but i just wanted to let
you know like
you know i was i was kind of salty
towards you because when you left to l.a
i thought you're going to take me with
you
are you my child take me with like we're
going to [ __ ] frolick together to la
so he literally was upset at me because
i didn't quote unquote take him with him
i was like you thought you thought you
guys were partners yeah
but even so how is that my
responsibility for you like your success
is not my responsibility we weren't even
a duo like what is this what is this
nonsense i thought i was gonna be able
to get a piggyback ride from you david
it's not like it was like you and bart
where you guys created a channel
together yeah it was a partnership it
was a partnership this we were doing two
separate things oh my god and then he
goes yeah i just wanted to let you know
like you know i'm i'm super like hyped
and proud of you which you already know
when somebody says that there's
something else coming after but yeah he
goes but he goes i think you just got
lucky and you know i don't think you're
funnier than me i think like i'm just as
funny as you i'm like wait are you
dissing me are you congratulating what
is this [ __ ] and i just wrote back to
him something very simple i was like if
you were talented you would be here and
not over there writing a facebook
message yeah and that's all i wrote but
a lot of people write it off as like oh
you're just lucky yeah i was like you
know what i'll admit there is a bit of
luck in there right but there's the
other part of the equation as well of
course like what was that phrase when it
it's like when opportunity meets like
hard work or something you you know when
um preparation meets uh
opportunity yes yeah then that's
considered luck exactly like you
prepared for this moment and you got to
seize it and so for him it was like okay
you you chose to stay back work this job
because it was more comfortable i was
like when i left i had [ __ ] like 20
bucks in my bank account yeah so how
where the [ __ ] is that look like you
weren't there like youtube wasn't making
money at the time i just had to go and
see what happened and you know it just
turned out that it worked well yeah it
blows my mind because i think like
everyone that i know or at least if they
watch my content right i want everyone
to win like i want everyone to do well
right but some people out there believe
that like you doing worse is them
getting ahead yeah like it's like that
crabs in the bucket mentality like me
and bart we used to have this um old
group of friends and and we had a really
competitive friend and this guy
was always talking about how like oh
bart's the leader and i gotta get ahead
and i'm like how is he the leader like
well for once i'm i'm i once in a while
come into the group and hang out and go
bodyboarding but i'm like
to me it just seems like a handful of
guys that like to get together and party
and drink and like surf or whatever
right like you know this you know bart's
like autistic right
but then like like he's been telling all
of our friends like oh one day you know
like i'm gonna be the leader and not
bart and like he's always had this plot
against bart yeah and i'm like
what he's bart's just a goofy ass dude
yeah with the [ __ ] lego head
he's my autistic friend like we all love
we all love the dude you know like [ __ ]
that's crazy how people just create
competition in their head yeah and then
it was his life goal to like destroy his
ass and i'm like
this has happened to me too like this
has i think everyone has an example of
this where you're just [ __ ] picking
your nose living life enjoying it you
think this dude is one of your bestest
friends and you have an authentic
relationship and you didn't know that
like deep down inside they [ __ ] hated
you yeah and they just wanted to win and
they just wanted to make you feel like
less than and i think it comes from
people who are like thinking that your
destruction is their win
you know we i like i've always had this
conversation with especially younger
people and i think a lot of young people
do that because they feel like they have
to keep up in this like imaginary race
but like i always say it's just you
figure out whatever makes you happy you
know because for me
i figured out too it's i was just
watching this um conversation uh mr
beast you know mr beast makes
[ __ ] millions and millions of views
do you know how modest he lives yeah he
he's not balling yeah he puts all of his
money back into his projects and it's
not even him just saying it for pr
purposes they were asking why don't you
have a big house why don't you have all
these other things he goes i find it
stupid that i should pay more money to
live in a bigger box
and that's how i agree because somebody
would look at him and they would expect
him to live this very lavish lifestyle
exactly but he's figuring out what makes
him happy yeah i just want to create
dope content and then you know he's
probably he does well for himself but
he's not balling out you know yeah and
he he makes balling out money like he
makes 30 40 mil easily right and
it's just we're in a different era now
where we don't have to kind of live in
the norms of like all right at this age
you have to have a house at this age you
have to be married with this much money
and this and that and i think the
quickest way to become broke is to try
to prove that you're rich and i always
have this because like there's so many
people that are like looking for
validation and they're like oh i want
people to know that i'm rich so i'm
gonna buy this this and that and then
like do you actually like those cars do
you actually like that house or are you
doing it because you want people to talk
about you yeah and then for me i go the
opposite route i said the more money i
get
the more homeless i'm gonna pretend to
be
and i've been playing this game for the
last year it was [ __ ] hilarious but i
had to kind of come out and you know
break my own like like troll but um yeah
like you know we all did really well in
crypto yeah a lot of us you know some of
us broke a million whatever and on top
of that we have other businesses going
on investments we don't talk about
everything because obviously it doesn't
really apply to the youtube world and at
the end of the day we're like in the
comedic space yeah we're not in the
you know motivational space even if
people might find inspiration or
whatever like we just talk about life
and jokes and funny [ __ ] so i feel kind
of awkward and maybe it's a little bit
of like imposter syndrome but it feels
weird to get out of my joke character
and then start talking about like all
the other things that we're doing
because it's like
i don't want to do that like i don't
want to break that facade i don't want
to break that image of who i am as like
this dumb jokester i just don't want
people to
kind of follow
or maybe learn from the things that we
don't care about right so money is a
means for us to do to live life happily
and do what we want right but i don't
think it's like one of the things that
make me quote unquote happy yeah so if i
say okay well we're doing this we're
doing this this and that i don't want
people to look at it and say oh because
of money that's why he's happy it's the
opposite yeah and you grow with not a
lot of money money just means
opportunity but even then i have a
ceiling for that
like
mario and i think a lot of people are
surprised they go what's your ideal home
mine's a three bed two bath i don't have
i don't want
maybe a four bed if at most but i don't
need anything bigger i grew up in a
household with me my brother my mom and
my dad and sometimes you know at a
certain point my grandpa and i never
felt like my space was small i never
felt that i needed more in terms of a
home i never went to somebody else's
house and said oh i wish i lived in this
home i've i never had that so i don't
generally base my happiness on wanting
more material things i have a certain
goal that i like but that's only because
in terms of money money creates certain
opportunities for me like me being able
to i don't know if i'm retired and i
have enough money i could have a family
and be around my kids because my parents
couldn't do that they were always
working 24 7. so mine buys freedom yes i
think it buys freedom it buys time it
buys like dreams because like let's say
we have a crazy idea to do something
stupid right it's like i want to have 10
billboards back to back of me and a
speedo just because
money can do that for you like mr beast
right like if you just want to plant a
million [ __ ] trees out there money
can do that for you like obviously we
can do a lot of things without it but it
just speeds up the process and if you
see it as like one time and this one guy
said yo money is is is nothing money is
just choices that's all it is yeah money
is just
the more money you have the more choices
in the world you'll have because if you
think on a budget everything is limited
so it's like if you had the option to
have a [ __ ] 10 home mansion or a
shack
well if you had the money you can
actually choose the shack because you
want the shack instead of being forced
to live in the shack and that's me
i can buy all these things but that's
not my lifestyle and strategy
this podcast is brought to you by babble
my friends pierre what do you think ah
bonjour miss you
i think babel is tired magnifique
because i say it comes from the soul and
it teaches you how to speak our language
the way that we speak all right get the
[ __ ] out of here you french [ __ ] listen
babel if you guys don't know what babel
is
babel is the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
because it's addictively fun and an easy
way to learn a new language and it's
done
properly 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go and by the way it was developed
by over a hundred language experts when
you guys were in high school i know for
a fact that whatever spanish that you
learned or whatever foreign language you
learned you forgot all of it because
number one the way that they taught you
was weird and on top of that it wasn't
really applicable in your everyday
talking life well babel's different my
friends you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish french
italian and even german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babble my friends right now save up to
60 off your subscription when you go to
babble.comgb
that's babble.com g before up to 60 off
your subscription babble language for
life and that's what i always want to
push is that like being in line with
what your happiness is and what your
goals are and what you desire out of
life being in line with all those things
is gonna help you thrive and help you be
happy like
trying to look for approval from other
people as in like oh you know everyone's
gonna think i'm dope if i have a [ __ ]
four-story house then i gotta get that
you know and you don't really wanna
you're gonna be paying these [ __ ]
bills on a place that you don't even use
um
i think that's the road to unhappiness
is living for the validation of other
people but i think that's so difficult
to do because like i think the hardest
thing to do is for people to look at
themselves and being like
what do i want and what is going to make
me happy
while people laugh at me
and i think that's the thing that's hard
to stomach is like people don't want to
get judged and laughed at and whatever
so
i'm just like i didn't want to be a part
of that group who's just constantly
talking about this like
um toxic hustle culture yeah yeah you
know cause like we do hustle we do like
making businesses but the purpose behind
it isn't just for the sake of the
numbers and for cloud and for all these
other things that i actually don't
associate with yeah and there's a lot of
negative connotations when it comes to
being businessman or entrepreneur or
whatever right especially now because
like there's a lot of people struggling
and then there's a lot of people balling
and then like i feel like the middle
class is kind of dividing right and then
there's a lot of
you know ideas of what a boss is or what
a capitalist is and
when you kind of throw yourself in that
world
we all know that there's more than just
the stereotypical idea of what a
businessman is a greedy bastard who
exploits employees or whatever right
like we know there's so many great
people
in this realm of business
but a lot of people don't know that and
for me it's too complex to kind of like
deal with and it's just easier to come
on like jk news or here or whatever just
talk about life yeah yeah and just be a
human being and so all of these
achievements and all these other things
that we actually get ourselves into i
think
we don't talk about it enough sometimes
yeah i mean
also too i just i feel even though i
talk about a lot of personal stories
um a lot of these personal stories are
something that happened way in my past
right and then the names that i give out
are all different names and these i'll
change small details because the reason
why i do that is because i'm also
though i do tell a lot about my personal
strides and all these like stories
the other stuff the other 80 that people
don't know i keep really private right
and
i think i like that i'm not doing it on
purpose to prove a point or anything but
there are certain things that i enjoy
that i like to keep to myself yeah you
know and i think we're in a world now
where everybody feels like they if
they're not sharing something then it's
not real
but
that's just you living a life of
comparison like what is like the biggest
what's it what did they say like
comparison is like the biggest thief of
joy right and i just don't like living
that world
a lot of the times people say oh you
don't post about mario a lot because i
don't have to yeah like that's not my
responsibility to make you feel
comfortable about my personal
relationships you think you love her as
much as you don't [ __ ] parade her all
day yeah you know i mean that's that if
that's what you do that's what you do
but i can't live my personal
relationship with my lady based on how
you would conduct yourself so just the
biggest thing is just mind your [ __ ]
business you know and the things that i
do choose to share is because
it's not really thought out just i just
wanted to share it at the time yeah
there's no like master plan when it
comes to these things for me i just do
it because i do it and if i enjoy it i
enjoy it which kind of goes to the topic
of the biggest
biggest surprise so
man it's been it's been kind of an
ordeal but we're crazy yeah we have been
working on this secretly and we haven't
really talked about it just because
obviously speaking of secret businesses
yeah
so
me joe
and his cousin greg are actually opening
up a store a junebe in
oahu yes baby it's been it was supposed
to be open in january but damn let me
tell you guys this has been uh in the
works for quite some time now um me and
david we absolutely love hawaii like
we're always there second home almost
like i actually have family from there
and um
the thing is we've been talking i would
say since we've been doing our like
trips out there it's like man wouldn't
it be cool if we had like a reason to
live here just for a little bit or maybe
even like do something to contribute to
the community or like have a piece of us
here somehow and we kept talking and
talking and one day was like why don't
we do a spam musubi stuff or why don't
we do a like a restaurant here or
whatever because we're both into food
and we like the community and we love
the food culture in oahu
and then it was like we have restaurants
that were invested into why don't we
just bring that here yeah yeah yeah yeah
and the cool thing is too is
i think just to kind of wrap back to
kind of how we create and the reason why
we do things is simply to just like
supplement the stuff that makes us
really happy so if hawaii makes us happy
we have a community out there and
you know uh
greg's family is originally from yeah
hawaii too right yep he um
his dad uh grew up in pearl city it's
that it's a crazy story his dad told me
like he when he was a kid he he worked
on this uh watercress farm
and he saw
um the attack on pearl harbor from the
hills and as a kid he just saw the bombs
and he was just like what the heck and i
think that inspired him to join the
military and all that stuff and see the
world but
um man the people that grew up there
during that time it's a whole different
hawaii from what it is today vince told
me this crazy story and i might be
paraphrasing it you know incorrectly but
um
i personally i didn't know this it's
probably like in history books but i
guess like americans or the government
issued a warning to like japanese people
that obama was going to drop but it was
all in english oh really yeah like the
atomic bomb yeah wow so
so in hiroshima they
like planes dropped off flyers saying
hey obama is coming obama's coming like
they couldn't [ __ ] do it in japanese
like exactly so there was a few educated
people in terms of educating what i mean
like they knew how to read english oh
okay and they would let you know the
people in the vicinity know that obama
is coming but that's not everybody and
so they actually gave them a warning and
so i think
uh vince's either grandmother or
grandfather they read it they read it
and they you know warned people around
them and then while she was on the train
leaving she saw the bomb drop that's
nuts how [ __ ] nuts is that [ __ ]
that's crazy that era is is wild man
that world war ii just people seeing the
crazy [ __ ] that they did
and um funny fun fact too because i knew
that our other business partner jeremy
he's also you know on uh the owner of
junebe and all that stuff
on the corporate end
when he made those posts about
june b hawaii and how he's proud that
you know the company that his ancestors
kind of like grew up like in hawaii
is going back and then i see these
pictures and i was like oh crap dude i
didn't know so i knew that his family's
from kauai but i didn't know they were
plantation peoples yeah yeah yeah
straight up like i didn't know how many
generations they went back but that's a
pretty good full circle thing his mom's
side you know i guess they have deep
roots in kauai
and then so i'm like
it's kind of a good feeling to know that
like the locals and the people that help
kind of contribute to hawaii are also
having a hand and bringing back a
business or creating a business concept
on the islands yeah and i think it's
important for us to like you know if
you're ever in waikiki like we're going
to give the combine a discount yeah like
we want to still be a part of the
community and that's just one location
that we'll have yeah you know who knows
what's gonna happen in the future
strategically i thought like business
sense wise it would make sense to get to
the place that would probably generate
the most foot traffic
and also have the most awareness because
everything in waikiki it's like
it's the most you know
global because when you have japanese
you have a lot of mainland you know
tourists and
half of the people that i meet like out
there
whether we're hiking at coco head or
whatever right
are
fans that are from the mainland
so they're like from texas chicago
whatever they're coming to visit the
islands and then they stop us yeah and
i'm like oh [ __ ] what's up dude so it's
a piece to kind of
i think it's like it's like a it's like
a piece to give to everybody yeah yeah
yeah it's been really it's been really
interesting like because i've never
i mean yeah we did the soft i've been
the software spot but this is like kind
of a whole other beast like it was it
was definitely a lot of stuff that
you're personally dealing with that i
didn't have to deal with when opening up
a soft serve yeah i'm like oh [ __ ]
there's so many uh things to deal do it
you know it's cause we're getting into a
place that's like top grade yeah so
they're they have so many rules because
it's like opening up a business on rodeo
drive right here in beverly hills it's
like if you have a grade a place you
have to use the top the best contractors
to build you have to do there's so much
red tape yeah because like they have
[ __ ] millions of dollars they have to
worry about
and then so it was the most strictest
process
while dealing with the pandemic while
dealing with shipping issues and all
this stuff and
the whole city went through a scandal in
government
it was just [ __ ] nuts yeah and so we
were supposed to open in january but a
lot of businesses if you if you actually
see this there they've been really
struggling to open in honolulu um and
some might be like you're [ __ ] crazy
why did you do it in the heart of the
pandemic
well
i don't lack vision i have vision i know
one day it's going to open up and so
when you get the pandemic special which
is you know things were just
lower in rent like prices were better
for uh real estate all this stuff
as in like
like
if you wanted to get a business lease
a lot of businesses were were basically
empty or failing or not open so they
were willing to give out great deals
so my plan was why don't i secure this
great deal during the pandemic
and you know when it opens i'll be
locked into something amazing yeah
because when you're opening up a
business while it's super popular busy
there's gonna be first off you can't
find a place to rent because there's
nothing open yeah and then the the rent
that you do find it's probably going to
be three times what it is today yeah so
that was just my kind of like future
thinking we locked in something amazing
and in a great location it's called the
royal hawaiian
and on top of that i think like we have
great people working with us landlords
in the community and i just feel really
good all around about it because i could
have opened up another spot here in la
or vegas where a lot of our supporters
and friends are but hawaii just has this
like
it's just it's just an excuse really to
be there more but i'm really just going
there so i could swim every morning yeah
it was [ __ ] interesting like when we
were talking earlier about like so i i
recently you know flew my parents out
here and then i've never really asked my
dad
about
kind of like our past and our history
and specifically about my grandparents i
didn't know
and it only hit me a little bit recently
that well so i remember when i was a kid
um my my grandpa used to play this
i think it's like mahjong or some type
of
somebody can correct
yeah it's called uh i think it's called
not you noti but
i forgot what it was called takti or
something i don't know what the [ __ ] it
is some korean person let me know
but one day when he was playing it
around i was asking him to teach me how
to play this right and then out of
nowhere he brings out this piece of
paper
and he starts writing in japanese oh
[ __ ] right so he starts writing like
whatever you know whatever kanji and
stuff like that
and then he was telling me that he could
speak japanese and i'm like what the
[ __ ] why do you know how to speak
japanese a lot of korean grandparents
can't exactly so i i didn't know this
yeah but then i was talking to my dad
about that me remembering him doing that
he goes oh you don't remember when they
used to fight they would only talk to
each other in japanese yeah i i mean i
didn't really know the dark history of
that stuff when i was a kid but i do
remember going to
korean friends houses and their
grandparents couldn't speak english but
they'd be able to speak japanese so we
would communicate like that
or like
some vietnamese
some chinese
like i would just go over and then
they're like oh you're japanese and then
they'll start speaking japanese to me
but they can't speak any english at all
so i'm like
and then my parents you know told me
like why they know how to speak it but
like at the time as a child i didn't
know you know but it was cool i just
thought yeah
but it i think it has an effect on your
mind like where it's like oh then a lot
of people must learn japanese like the
way they learn english like it's a
popular language that's what i thought
yeah i think
it was like um
maybe like 40 years of occupation yeah
it was also it was a high it's predates
world war ii yeah because when um after
world war one
japan started you know like well i think
it was even during but in between world
war one to two they were already
expanding
and they were
colonizing
like
like taiwan
you know china
korea
and korea was one of the first countries
after they fought with russia that they
invaded and then um
you know i think like yeah they they
they had it occupied for almost like
40-something years and then world war ii
broke out after world war ii broke out
that's when korea got their independence
and then that's when north and south
fought yeah so it's been a lot of uh i
think like um
kind of like a colonial
like under different people's rules yeah
this podcast is sponsored by better help
my friends betterhelp has been a
longtime sponsor of geniusbrain because
i use betterhelp and i freaking love it
a lot of the times people do not talk
about mental health and i will
constantly reiterate this if you care
about your physical health you should
worry about your mental health just as
much because health is more than just on
the physical side if you're not taking
care of your mentals
you're gonna go a little mental people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches even teeth
grinding and even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
and over eating when i started using
better health my life got a lot better
because i got to let off some steam and
collect my thoughts with somebody who
wasn't really judging me with my own
personal therapist and guess what my
friends do i have to remind you how dope
it is better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
give it a try and see if online therapy
can help lower your stress
genius brainlisters get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com genius
that's b-e-t-t-e-r that's why korean
people's folk music is so sad because so
much war has so much war and whaling
like we were like a province of china i
heard at one point
i was like damn we were just owned by
everybody dude that's why all of our
music if you my grandpa used to listen
to these old korean records
and it was you know traditional folk
music but it just sounds like somebody
is wailing for hours ah
i'm like dude
how is this the [ __ ] he's over here
listening to this stuff like damn this
is my [ __ ]
people love that [ __ ] but if you think
about japan and korea's comeback though
like
japan after world war ii was like
pretty much yeah and then out of all of
a sudden became a like top economy and
korea is crushing it right now and i
think korea is super remarkable because
like
one it was never a nation nation like
one nation right like
if you look at ancient korea it's been
like several different kingdoms
and it was a vassal state of china some
kingdoms
and then
here comes you know like
japan taking it over here's here comes
you know all this north like the war
from north korea this it's been broken
up so it's really a brand new country
and they established nationalism
identity
and like technology and everything since
1950 something
i heard i'm not sure how true this is
but it's like one of the most fastest
like economic turnarounds like any
country has ever had with amazing wi-fi
it's just it's literally fiber optic
throughout the whole [ __ ] country
crazy bro like so every time i travel i
do the whole pocket wi-fi [ __ ] right
because it's way better and i was
shocked this was like 2 000 i wanna say
like
nine or ten right and i was just shocked
at the [ __ ] technological
advancements it's like nuts the internet
is so good yeah and i was like what the
heck how is this possible everywhere has
wi-fi
and i'm like man i can upload youtube
[ __ ] videos this way do i have fiber
optic at this place right now yeah if i
because i record this in 4k i have
multiple cameras the file size is like
10 11 gigs it takes eight minutes to
upload the whole thing oh [ __ ] yeah it's
so [ __ ] fast wow because at the last
place i lived it took about like an hour
and a half to upload a full video and
that thing was like maybe five five gigs
dang
like 10 gigs like in eight minutes
ridiculous
that's true that's crazy man i wish we
had that like in everywhere yeah i mean
it's crazy because i don't i can't even
remember time before
like i was just thinking about the other
day when i was like stretching i'm like
i'm watching something as i'm stretching
like before i just had a stretch like i
was there was there was nothing else i
wasn't distracting myself or something
but i always have something to entertain
myself with oh yeah at all times that's
true and we're kind of in that
mid-generation where we had 56k modems
yeah we had that we when we had to watch
porn it was like it would take a good
like two days to download this 30 second
clip i know and then you would jack off
to that for [ __ ] months you had one
picture that your friend gave you in a
[ __ ] floppy disk
takes like 10 seconds to load and [ __ ]
you guys are so lucky porn was so hard
back in the day
we had to work for that [ __ ] do you
think it's [ __ ] with your head now
that you have so much access to just
online non-stop
dude i really think so because when
right when i wake up i grab my phone
yeah
i i don't know why i do that [ __ ] yeah i
wake up and i grab my phone and i look
at it all the [ __ ] time checking my
crypto
checking my [ __ ] messages i know
and um it started [ __ ] with my head
because then
when i'm when i wake up and do it i'm
half asleep so then when i'm half asleep
whatever
is happening here takes over
my emotions in mind
but then like when i'm when i'm fully
awake right i can [ __ ] around with my
phone and it's like oh this country got
bombed oh well it's like nothing happens
to me emotionally whatever right
because i'm i don't know i think we're
all desensitized but for some reason if
i do it right when i wake up let's say
like i'm stressed out because
something's happening on on this
business or whatever i got to get it
done fast or just all kinds of [ __ ] like
it [ __ ] with me man
yeah i i think a lot of people don't
have that wherewithal to understand how
you start your day is a representation
of how the rest of your day will go yeah
that's why you know you hear a lot of
people who are life coaches say start
your day with cleaning up your room and
starting fresh you know start with some
type of positivity because it really
does affect your mind state like if i
read an email that pisses me off the
rest of the day right i'm pissed that's
why i started my day jacking off because
it's a great mood but i just go right
back to sleep and i'm not productive so
it's like
i wake up now and i go
i go to the little genius brain dojo
outside and then karate and i just
[ __ ] stretch that's tight i open the
door and there's like mountains over
here i can look at and i just stretch
and i listen to music and i just relax
because i i i'm not going to look at the
thing that's going to make my day
terrible yeah because it just it puts me
in a [ __ ] [ __ ] mood it does man it's
all about controlling like what you
allow enter your mind yeah and then like
you know how they say [ __ ] like oh you
let them live
you know in your mind rent free or
whatever right and it's really true it's
like
and also you have to get good at
being able to block out certain things
or or removing certain things because
like there's only limited space that we
have in our heads it's like i call it
like our mental real estate right like
this city's already built you can't
fit more [ __ ] yeah so then if you
introduce thoughts that you don't want
into it like it's like a virus it's
gonna stay there so like
a lot of my [ __ ] recently has been about
how do you like kind of
maneuver through all of this and
one of the things that actually works
that blew my [ __ ] mind was just like
going out into nature
because when i'm sitting in the room and
i'm like you know what
i think this is what's causing it it's
me sitting still in a [ __ ]
caged room yeah and i'm like my mind is
just representing what it feels it's
trapped so i'm like why don't i just
take a walk why don't i just go out take
a hike why don't i go swim and then i
realize like when i'm in hawaii when i'm
in like you know the mountains or
whatever
hiking
laughing with my friends or just
swimming
it just feels so much better and all the
same thoughts that come into my head it
doesn't affect me yeah so i'm like oh
maybe it's physiological maybe there's
something here where like as a human
being you just have to be a
natural creature just walking around
yeah yeah yeah because i remember we
used to do those walks when you're
losing weight yeah and i was like it's
so weird how just some sun and walking
around the block can really like do
dramatic [ __ ] to your mind yeah it feels
really good like now i don't walk as
well it's been kind of cold and rainy
but you know when it gets warm the first
thing i like to do is walk yeah wake up
stretch and then go for like a two three
mile walk and then the rest of my day is
good dude when we're in hawaii because
we have a place there
and it's gonna be fun dude because i
have this routine now where i wake up in
the morning i bought a couple of mopeds
uh we just go out
we're right next to the beach in the
park
park our mopeds we just do a couple of
like workouts or whatever and we just
jump in the ocean and it's [ __ ] warm
especially if you go like during the
summer right so it's like you're jumping
into a nice jacuzzi just [ __ ]
swimming and then the day starts off
like you
you're a [ __ ] cute little baby that
just got bathed
in the sink by mom yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then and then you go out and you
know breakfast food hawaii does
breakfast food like no other right so
every day we're like we had a list on
yelp of like let's hit up these
different breakfast restaurants i got
some prime rib loco moco man it put me
right back to sleep
i gotta be careful with food out there
man we've been going to eat like crazy
i'm just gonna maybe i don't know eat
get an order of zippies and try to eat
that throughout the day because that
portion order that portion is huge man
yeah well i always order a lot too i
always get the loco moco i get a side of
chili and then i'll do like i don't know
like they'll have like a manapur or some
[ __ ] like that yeah you know but i can't
wait dude because i want to
i get to live the life that i've been
dreaming about of like just wake up go
out there [ __ ] swim maybe hike um and
then just get to work you know
yeah i mean
we're really just kind of building the
lifestyle that we've always
wanted or maybe not even so much wanted
i think it's more of a lifestyle that i
didn't know that i really enjoyed yeah
right and i think you know as as i get
older we've been doing entertainment for
a very very long time now
my reason for wanting to do
entertainment was simply just because i
wanted to yeah i didn't have any lofty
goals to win like an oscar i didn't have
enough you know i didn't have that i
just
really enjoyed the process and that's
how it's always been so
for me entertainment was just a thing
that i kind of fell into yeah even
though yeah i wanted to be a huge
stand-up comic once i started doing
youtube i realized i didn't really have
that one i just liked
having fun yeah and then we somehow made
a living off of having fun so now that's
gonna be my entire life goal is to make
money while having fun yeah in whatever
facet that is it doesn't matter what it
is it could be entertainment it could be
opening up this june b it could be i
don't know [ __ ] i don't know starting
a kid's channel i'll figure it out i
think that's the key
of my happiness is like being able to do
businesses with my friends
and then like creating those dope-ass
memories and then just being able to
like have fun that's all it is
and
and yeah i have goals like i want to
achieve certain goals like you know i
want to open up these businesses or
whatever right but then
i've never had
the first place goals yeah like i never
had the trophy goals none of that stuff
and i think that's why we've been at the
top right like i never i never have that
because sometimes to be the top
it doesn't help to work with your
friends
and and that's kind of always been the
reason for like with jk you know like i
kept certain people there for a long
long time
when maybe i shouldn't have um but it
wasn't about that it was just about like
hey like we just like coming in here and
[ __ ] around let's do it yeah you know
or whatever uh and it's the same concept
i think with a lot of the businesses
that we do it's just like
yeah let's this is an idea let's get
together and let's [ __ ] have fun with
it and then you know what are you bored
of it yeah i'm bored of it i don't know
do you want to keep going i don't know
let's do something new all right
and that's kind of life you know like
yeah yeah it's been really fun living
like that though and i think a lot of
people are going to figure out
it's hard to say too because you could
tell somebody who's really young the
same type of advice but you just kind of
have to go through it to really
understand what it is because
if my now self told my younger self the
same thing i would be like [ __ ] you oh
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about right or you would maybe
feel it but you don't know how to really
put it into motion yeah right and it
just takes trials and tribulations for
you to understand what's important to
you and what's not because i don't see
myself having this my state when i was
younger because i personally didn't know
what my desires were i thought i wanted
to be the biggest fan of comic i thought
this but then it turns out that number
one place didn't mean anything to me i
just really enjoyed the process yeah and
i think a lot of people have to enjoy
that too
it's impossible for everybody to be
number one i think it's a
it's good for you if you're a kobe type
of person you have kobe mentality then
do that type of [ __ ] i don't have kobe
mentality i have [ __ ] uh i don't know
if you guys even know who this is
lawrence thunderberg he's uh
like like most people don't know who the
[ __ ] that is who's that exactly
basketball player i'm a lawrence
thunderbird i made it to the nba i was i
was good for what i did you know and i'm
good but that's that's where i enjoy it
like even like kickboxing right started
it i did it to the point where i felt
like i was decent like a spar and then
that was it but i mean you're
the things that you get into though is
you still get into a you do you still do
it and you have great work ethics and
you still crush it because like we all
did it but then you surpassed us and
then it's like yeah but you're not going
to be the number one [ __ ] tybo master
of the world you know like like
i don't even have a want to even compete
no because you just enjoy
doing it right and i think we're all the
same in that same thing it's like we
like to experiment we like to try we
like to just say [ __ ] it let's do this
and let's have something that we do
together yeah and i think that's the
best because like we've seen the dark
side of
being pure gold chasers
when it's only about the goal
and then some people they get to this
point where like they care so much about
the goal that they don't care about
their friends their family nothing else
and they're they're just
accomplishing one and then the other and
then they feel unfulfilled and they're
always stressed they're always sad like
i have friends who have like [ __ ]
billionaire dreams or like just whatever
and they're [ __ ] miserable and i'm
like i would never want your life and
the sad thing is you know when when i
had those same thoughts i was like
telling myself
am i just saying that because i want to
feel better that i don't have as much as
them but i really sat and thought about
it i was like no they're miserable like
because they verbally said it you know
because i have to sometimes want to
check myself too it's like am i do
having these bad habits because no wait
i don't really care about money like do
you think it's a it's kind of like an
excuse like you're just like yeah
because i'm not number one this is how i
cope yeah so i like double check myself
and then i really it's not that it's
just i i know what i like and i know
what i want and i think
you know and i've said this before too
where i look at my parents and my
parents have never said they hated their
life yeah even though we did not have it
that great which is a really admirable
thing because i know a lot of people who
have so much but they say they hate
their lives i said why did my parents
who we were [ __ ] broke dude like you
know you know how we grew up like we all
grew up poor i never heard my mom say i
hate my life yeah i hate this i hate
that i've i never heard it that's true i
never heard my mom complaining right
then she had a shitty life
[ __ ] my dad left her ass all alone
[ __ ] had a deal with two sons and
but she never complained yeah and that's
why it blew my mind when i started to
hear people complain about their lives
and i was just like what the [ __ ] genius
farts if you're hearing these ads that
means you guys are the reason why this
podcast is continually sponsored so make
sure that you check out our sponsors
click the links because this podcast is
brought to you by ipvanish my friends
did you know that browsing online using
incognito mode doesn't actually protect
your privacy that's right without added
security you might as well just give
away all your private data and you know
pictures of your freaking butthole let
me tell you something that's why i use
ipvanishvpn to make it easy to stay
truly private and secure on the internet
if you're trying to snoop around my
stuff you can't you stupid idiot because
i use ipvanish and you're too dumb to
even know that so suck my butt ipvanish
is offering an incredible 70 off their
yearly plan for our listeners with a
30-day money-back guarantee that's just
like getting nine months for freaking
free yes this is an awesome deal so go
to ipvanish.com brain and use
promotional code brain and claim your 70
savings that's
ipvanish.com as an ipva i-p-v-a-n-i-s-h
dot com
brain well yeah it's i think that's why
we don't like complainers yeah because
we never grew up around that we always
had people who were problem solvers or
they appreciated the things that they
had and that's them enjoying the process
yeah my mom never said she hated her job
and her job was [ __ ] hard my dad
never hated his life he was a full-time
pastor and he ran a business like 80
hours a week because they're survivors i
think that's the difference right
um but also it's perspective of what you
can stomach because some people whose
their their normal is not our normal
yeah so i think that's why we vibe and
then you know
they probably vibe with their own ideas
of what is normal and what is safe and
what is scary more painful and i had to
make my choices where i had to cut
people out
the people who would consistently
complain about the life are the ones i
had to cut out yeah because it was the
same concept of me waking up and dealing
with negative energy and it would [ __ ]
up the rest of my [ __ ] and it's
stressful yeah because i feel like we
should be a unit that can you know
on the same page like we want to survive
we want to have fun and we we have the
same you know kind of ideas about the
world but
over time when you have people
uh within your realm who basically
are always defeated or or maybe even
depressed or like it takes a toll on you
and it's like we're not therapists we're
not psychologists years ago too i had to
cut out some money this is like six
seven years ago and the main reason why
i cut this person out is because no
matter how much they won no matter how
many
gigs they were booking no matter how
much money they were making they always
wanted to be the person in the group
that everybody had to feel sorry for so
they loved playing the victim he loved
playing that victim card and that person
to this day doesn't really have good
friends and like i even had to cut out
people who were friends with her because
i dislike them even more than her
because in front of her yeah they would
praise her say oh you're doing so well
you're kicking it and then they would
come to me like oh she's so fake oh
that's that's horrible i was like you're
worse than her now yeah because she's a
she's a weird weirdo piece of [ __ ]
that's dealing with her [ __ ] but the
difference is you you're a snake now
because you're telling her oh she's
awesome but you come to me and you say
she's [ __ ] dumb it's like now you're
a piece of [ __ ] yeah because you should
be the friend that's
checking them yeah and i'm i just it
just blows my mind how like people
operate like that
because because i don't think in these
ways
sometimes we have snakes that slip
like within the group within people that
we know
and then like i'm just so blindsided
like what the [ __ ] man
um
why do you treat people this way like in
front of them you want to give them
support and you think you have an
authentic authentic relationship and
then behind their backs they're just
talking all this [ __ ] they're doing all
these things and it's like what the hell
is happening it's also too why do you
want to waste your energy and time with
people that you really don't want to be
around and when i look at that and
obviously with this person you know
they're probably you know they're famous
and stuff they they see
that part of it and so they want to keep
them in their back pocket just in case
yeah so you're just you're 10 times
worse than that person is that person
just has an issue of wanting to be
pitied all the time which is obnoxious
but you're a little snake yeah so that
person has to be cut out as well i think
that's one thing i've learned over time
just like dealing with people
is that um
a lot of people have many different
faces that they wear
is like
what you see
and what you think they are
a lot of the times isn't true
and i just been lucky that i think like
within most of the people that we're
around they're true to themselves and
maybe it's because like people that are
fake or whatever we spot it and kick
them out or
it's just that they don't feel
comfortable around us yeah so they might
be afraid of us or whatever it is but
then i i feel extremely lucky because i
feel like
either
because like i have you know i um you
know i have an audience on youtube they
suck up to me so i don't see the dark
side but i hear from other people you
know and then what a [ __ ] back they are
to people that
they can't benefit from
but i'm like i'm never treated shitty
from them you know yeah so
i mean everybody just has to look at
their own personal relationships with
somebody like even for me i the idea the
idea that people think that they know
somebody online it's it's asinine like
you don't know these people at all right
and
the like i always say too
you don't know somebody's a good person
or not just because of the they when
they put their best foot forward oh man
you know do we know so many people in
person
that [ __ ] act
so perfect
and their audience has no we can ruin so
many god dang people yeah it's like the
the just because you're likable doesn't
mean you're a good person that's what i
hate the most yeah it's like we act like
[ __ ] scumbags in real and on online
offline but we're very
you get what you get basically
we're not [ __ ] i mean like come on
dude what is there to hide right yeah
cuz like i'm talking about getting rim
jobs and [ __ ] like i don't give a [ __ ]
but like
there's people out there that have this
very
clean cookie cutter image of who they
are
and it would surprise the [ __ ] out of
people if
they knew what we knew exactly and i'm
like dude i don't do [ __ ] like that like
you're you're [ __ ] nuts
you know i mean i feel the stuff that i
got in trouble for is just for having
stupid opinions about things right and
i'm okay with that because i've never
said that i was a smart person i know
always said these are just opinions of
mine and they're always open for change
and it's happened a lot
but you would be surprised when somebody
if you look at somebody who caters their
content to always apologizing and doing
the right thing i guarantee you they're
a piece of [ __ ] behind doors because
there's absolutely no way that somebody
who constantly caters to other people
has a strong sense of identity they
don't impossible
because it's it's just i've never i've
yet to see it so when you when i see it
then i'll let you know but i haven't we
should do a video on genius brain 20
years from now calling i just like when
you when you just don't give a [ __ ]
anymore oh that's gonna be 20 years from
now that's gonna be like three years
from now you're probably gonna be like
all right this [ __ ] right here
they did this and this and this you guys
think that this person is [ __ ]
awesome just watch out and you would be
surprised too there's a reason why
they're like okay well if you know so
much about these people how come they
just don't you know say [ __ ] about well
they don't want to say [ __ ] about me
because if you do i have nothing to hide
yeah that's the that's the most
dangerous thing about people like me and
you we don't hide anything so you what
are you gonna say
you know what i mean i'm very upfront
about my flaws i'm very upfront about
the stuff that i've [ __ ] up on and
that i need to change and some of the
stuff that people think are bad
qualities i like that about myself so
i'll keep it right so
you know we could play that game
you're going to come out real bad
because i've never pretended i was an
angel you know but everybody else who
plays that image if you want to say i
don't know some [ __ ] about me let's
[ __ ] go let me tear you down from the
[ __ ] ground up i will rip you apart
it'll be a very very bad day for you
great for me bad for you that's a good
thing right you want people to talk
about you i think it's fun i do it like
we all talk about celebrity gossip we do
that [ __ ] it's fine
and i kind of like it because it's like
the best thing is
you know we should worry when people
don't talk about you yeah it's like
when they're creating their theories
when they're just having fun i mean we
do that [ __ ] when we look at the
kardashians it's fine but i think that
the real [ __ ] and this is the [ __ ] that
i don't like is when
there are people on youtube or just in
entertainment in general and we know
what a [ __ ] scumbag they are
and then they
go out and they fool people yeah i hate
that [ __ ] the most it's dishonest it's
unfair but then uh but then the other
part of me is like if they can
positively impact
the people and give them some hope or
give them some happiness i'm like it's
fine yeah yeah but at the end of the day
i know what their true colors are and
that's what kills me inside because i
just want to [ __ ] say it i just want
to tell you know but then
yeah yeah it's true though because as
long as they're doing something where i
guess people on the outside are
positively affected then i'll just leave
it as it is
and you know i just ain't no snitch
because i don't like doing that type of
[ __ ] i ain't no [ __ ] snitch it's
built in me but at the same time it's
just don't come at me though it would be
a very very they do
it's a very very bad time for you you
know it's funny because the things that
you sometimes i'll watch an episode the
[ __ ] that you'd say about people it's so
[ __ ] funny and it's true and i'm so
happy you do it because like
uh for the longest time on jk news like
you protected a lot of the people in the
group and we talked about this recently
too because
like
on jk like it was a co-ed mixed group of
people that wasn't always down for that
kind of drama attention yeah right so
like some of the members in the group
didn't want to track drama so
you were kind enough to hold your kind
of [ __ ] tongue and say i'm not going
to talk about other people in that light
but on genius brain i'ma go [ __ ]
hundred percent
right
yeah it's just like for me too like i
always keep it within a modicum like the
thing that a lot of people confuse is
they feel that i met them right it goes
oh you met me
i don't give a [ __ ] like unless you're
because it's just opinions you know what
i mean yeah like for example and it's
okay to roast everybody yeah
i get roasted all the [ __ ] time yeah
you know so it's like if you can't
if you can't take it then don't [ __ ]
dish it so i live in a very weird type
of world like i also don't like the
sense of you know whenever an asian
project comes out they're like are you
going to support it and i'm like no it
sucked why
like if it's good i will
it sucks if it sucks it sucks yeah you
might like it and that's completely okay
but i don't have to like it what what is
this unspoken rule it's like oh if you
and i had the same little [ __ ] eyes i
gotta [ __ ] support everything that
you do it sucked in my personal opinion
not as a general truth yeah but you know
when we talk about things in the art
realm and you know specifically like you
know film or art or whatever the [ __ ]
that it is it's open for interpretation
and if people don't feel anything about
it that means that it's not worthy to be
spoken about yeah so you know sometimes
when i say my opinions about things they
go oh well
you know they're it's it's in the asian
community why would you say that
i don't live like that it's art it's
open for interpretation and if people
don't talk about it then it just goes
away yeah
some of the asians that talk about it
positively even though they don't like
it they have a strategy of creating hype
so in hopes of getting another project
green yes so i get the politics behind
it i get it man it's been a hard road
for us like when we were kids we didn't
have asian projects that were getting
green lit in hollywood
i get that but also i understand that if
we don't scrutinize and critique things
we're not going to get better content
out of our people and i don't want to
feel like we got a consolation prize yes
i don't want to feel like we won an
asian award
because white people were like let's
give it to them they need one yeah and i
want to [ __ ] crush it i want to be
like [ __ ] i want to be like bts where
it's undeniable these guys they [ __ ]
came into america
by storm crushed it it's undeniable
people love their music yeah all it's
not it's not a petty love it's [ __ ]
they love it and i think that's the kind
of support i want to give to the asian
community is like to me i think this is
undeniable this is [ __ ] amazing and i
think it's great content yeah just to
silence people because you feel like you
have to do it because somebody has the
same skin color as you is it's absolute
nonsense it's tribalism and i don't
really like it i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
you know what i mean like
and i get it to a certain extent i kept
my opinions quiet about um crazy rich
asians for almost a year
because it was the first of its kind and
i understood the mission i took the
mission well guess what you got your
crazy rich asian that [ __ ] was trash it
was one of the worst [ __ ] movies i've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life i thought
it was one of the most funnest movies
ever and we can different opinions you
know made in that [ __ ] movie so
[ __ ] bad but i got i understood the
mission and i and i took it for what it
is you know but
at the same time people are like oh
don't say anything bad i'm like the more
you tell me not to do it the more i like
i know like don't don't tell me that you
know and what do they think you think
you're gonna create like an apocalypse
of oh what the [ __ ] am i david's
opinions got out all of a sudden
all of a sudden [ __ ] now it's gonna
drop in the drop box office it's not
gonna sell millions just like no i'm one
little blip in the universe i'm okay
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast you could catch
joe on all of his stuff joe jitsukawa
see it on jk films um check out our
store in oahu we'll probably up and
running and what i'm not sure but
hopefully our goal is summer yes by
summer time summer time babies if you
are on the island whether you're
visiting uh please come through
show us some love we have some island
exclusive flavors that you can't get at
any other store that's going to be at
our location uh so much love to our
ohana out there yup in hawaii and we
will definitely do a pandemic post
pandemic special meet and greet
where it's been a it's been a hard
several years we haven't been able to
see you guys face to face do any shows
and i think the first debut of us coming
out it's gonna be
in hawaii
maybe the whole jk fam i don't know like
barton geo says they're gonna be there
too yeah whenever the jk fans out there
they're probably gonna come through so
yeah come and say hi um hope you guys
enjoy our stuff we love this company
we're we're expanding fast
and you know it's been kind of a journey
dude like it's been one of those things
that we've been really yeah we post on
our stories here and there but we
haven't really talked about the growth
of the process
uh it's been a long time coming yeah
we've changed the company name has
changed like three times i know so much
growing pains but you know we're here
stay tuned guys because in well for now
if you guys want to support in the east
coast you could go to princeton and um
in texas you go to richardson
out here we got two roland and we got um
westwood but stay tuned for maybe
fullerton maybe irvine maybe oregon
maybe
we have several other places coming on
on live 2022 or 2023. yeah and our
biggest thing too is like
if you guys heard about me and food i
love uh accessibility accessibility is
my most important thing just because
we're kind of living in a world now
specifically with you know the whole
instagram phase that a lot of this stuff
is becoming elite like there's like a
certain elitism like oh you can only
have this if you have x amount of money
for us we're taking high grade matcha
and kind of making bringing it to the
masses that's right we're like the robin
hood of matcha we basically are you know
like i i like the the farm that we have
out in japan
is [ __ ] amazing it's like 100 years
old the it's all of our matcha is stone
ground the old way
um
little old japanese women are picking
the [ __ ] leaves like that's not even
a joke
like legit these women are up to my
belly button three teeth grandmas yeah
and there's a lot of attention and care
that you that you have with our products
that a lot of people charge more for and
we just make it accessible we eat the
cost so you guys can get it at a better
rate yeah well we could see you guys
next time uh genius brings every sundays
at 12pm uh catch joe on everything that
he does and check our journey out with
junebe macho and we'll see y'all next
time peace babies